- [Instructor] We're told
to complete the ratio table
to convert the units of
measure from hours to weeks,
or weeks to hours.
So we see here, they've told us already
that there's 168 hours for every one week.
One way to think about
it is the ratio of hours
for every week is 168 to
one, and then they calculate,
well if we have 1,176 hours,
how many weeks is that going to be?
So pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
Let's see, to go from 168 to 1,176,
what do we have to multiply by?
So, let's see, that looks
like we might be multiplying
by seven.
Let me try that out.
So 168 times seven is equal to...
Eight times seven is 56,
six times seven is 42 plus five is 47,
and then one times seven
plus four is indeed 1,176.
So we multiplied by seven,
we multiplied the number
of hours by seven,
so that means we're gonna have
seven times as many weeks.
So, one times seven is
just that is seven weeks.
Now, what about a situation
where we have three weeks,
how many hours is that going to be?
Well we are multiplying
our weeks by three,
so we would wanna multiply our hours.
We would wanna multiply
our hours times three.
So, 168 times three,
eight times three is 24,
six times three is 18, plus two is 20,
and then one times three
is three, plus two is five.
So, that would be 504 hours.
Let's do another example.
So, here they tell us the double
number lines show the ratio
of yards to miles.
So, the ratio of yards to miles.
It looks like we have 3,520
yards for every two miles.
For every two miles,
and you see that on this double
number line right over here.
Then they say how may
yards are in five miles?
So, why don't you pause this
video and try to figure it out.
Well the way my brain wants to do it is,
well let's just think about
how many yard are in each mile.
So, if the ratio's 3,520:2,
how could I rewrite this
ratio so it is how many yards
for every one mile.
So, to go from two to
one, I am dividing by two,
so I would wanna divide
this by two as well.
So, two goes into 3,520, let's see,
two goes into three one
time, one times two is two,
you subtract, you bring down the five.
Two goes into 15 seven
times, seven times two is 14,
subtract, we have one,
bring down that two,
two goes into 12 six
times, six times two is 12,
and we subtract, no remainder,
but then we're gonna
have one more zero here,
cuz we bring down that zero.
We say two goes into zero zero times,
zero times two is zero,
and we have no remainder,
and so this is 1,760.
So, we could put that here
on our double number lines.
So, if we have one mile
that is 1,760 yards.
Now, they're asking about five miles,
so three, four, five,
so we have five miles.
What is the number of yards?
Well if you multiply by five here,
you're also going to multiply
by five right over there.
So, what's 1,760 times five?
Well just figure it out.
1,760 times five, five times zero is zero,
five times six is 30.
Regroup that three cuz it's really 300s,
five times seven is 35,
plus three is 38, five times one is five,
plus three is eight.
So, there you go, 8,800 yards.
Let's do a few more examples.
Here, we're told there are
914.4 millimeters in a yard.
There are three feet in a yard.
How many millimeters are in a foot?
Okay, so one way to think about it,
you could say there's
914.4 millimeters per yard,
or you could say 914.4
millimeters per three feet,
since three feet and a
yard is the same thing.
So, if you wanna know per foot,
you would just divide
both of these by three.
So, let's do that,
and I'll just do it in
a different color here.
Three goes into 914.4, Three
goes into nine three times,
three times three is nine, subtract,
we get a zero bring down the one,
three goes into one zero times,
zero times three is zero,
subtract, get a one, and
bring down that four,
three goes into 14 four times,
gonna have this decimal right over here,
four times three is 12,
you subtract, and then,
so you get a two, bring down this four,
you get a 24, and lucky for us,
three goes perfectly into 24 eight times,
eight times three is 24,
24 you subtract,
now we have no remainder.
So, we have 304.8
millimeters for every foot.
Let's do one last example.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
So, let's just write this out in words.
So, it's $12 per pound of confetti.
So, you could do this
as $12 per 16 ounces.
16 ounces of confetti, and
so if we want it per ounce.
So, you could do this as a 12 to 16 ratio,
but we wanna say something to one ratio.
So, if you say per one ounce,
well we're dividing by 16 there,
so we would wanna divide by 16 as well.
So, this is going to be 12 divided by 16.
So, 12 divided by...
Well let me write it over here.
So 12 divided by 16 is
the same thing as 3/4,
just divide both of them by
four, and so this is 0.75,
or 75 cents, 75 cents per ounce,
or 75 hundredths of a dollar per ounce.
So, 0.75, and we're done.